[Music]
nba champion
husband father lyricist
you see me getting my fists off in that
nba tunnel but now
i'm the drip director welcome to the
drip university
i am the drip professor i am
the dean of drip i am
president as we all know we're at home
right now
as we all try and keep each other safe
and miss this kovid 19 outbreak
um but we all know that will not stop
the drip
we have collabed with gap once again and
we are here to
deliver a little direction to a young
man's trip
i got rox brown here um to help me to
style this
uh this go round after stylist when you
go
back in time and you look at your
outfits are you proud every time
every time every time okay that was
always on point when
when the point was happening i feel like
my my video should fade in
what's going on you can see me
i can see you we could all see you
you can still see me i left
today we're gonna style sham he's 22
years old he's a photographer from
atlanta
and his friends and family say he need a
little help with the drip so you know
what we got to do we got to help him
with his style today
what's up i'm sean scott and i'm a
photographer from atlanta
three words that describe my current
style is creative
elusive and relaxed damn style his style
is like he'll wear
whatever he could get his hands on to be
honestly he'll just throw on whatever
yeah this is my favorite shirt
i like it a lot because it's big and it
reminds me of like
a bowling dad like someone who just goes
to the bowling alley
or it reminds me of like the 90s
skateboarders you know like
i like that fashion a lot my friends and
my family would describe my style as
relaxed laid back and minimal i like to
see shannon play with the more of a
color palette they play with the earth
tones for him to look fresh and cozy
always
i'm just asking for help please help me
grab what's up i'm iman i'm the drift
director
it's nice to meet you man uh you know
bleacher report reached out
said that we can we can do this for you
man we've been doing this collab with
gap so this is rox brown one of the only
people i'ma trust on some clothes
but we want to know fashion wise
if we went and found a picture of you
say five years ago
and you know you always use this out and
about got dressed
would you be proud of how you dress i
was pretty decent i wasn't that good i
was wearing b-neck cashmere sweaters
with skinny jeans like i wasn't that
i wasn't peanut
all right so we're going to elevate your
style we actually
got to go through the collection with
gap and um
pick out some stuff i'm going to let
rocks take you through some stuff
you know certain styles that you could
wear for different
uh situations so first things i know you
you you know
your shooter take pictures and sometimes
you gotta drop down get the angles
you might have to climb on something to
get the angles so
i got some some cargos for you right
here
with a classic white tee you see a man
over there in the white tee the crispy
gap white teeth
this one got a little bit of texture on
it it gets better though i got you this
this upcycled yellow jacket it's
actually a rain jacket it was a wine but
it's not that hard
you see that you see that texture it's
like it's like a windbreaker
with that bucket hat that we sent you
throw that on real quick
get the bucket hat exactly boom it's a
look
that's how we going for the shoot
okay okay spin
bend back up
okay i got a tip for you you look like
you're like a tired jacket around your
your waist kind of guy is that you yeah
like this you gotta cross it like this
you know what i'm saying like do that oh
remember that that's fire
oh yeah you flip the hook down like that
uh-huh
and then you go under the arm yeah yeah
go under one arm yeah
yep but then you see how you got that
that hiked up right there you just got
to adjust it a little bit
i see like this you want it to go low
exactly you can also do a carlton banks
and just
yeah if i want to be on my bougie like
you know
selene something yeah
it's crazy that the moment you got this
yellow jacket like i see the confidence
go up
you really right you really like that
that jacket
i mean this is a signature it's the
style of it there's a signature i'll pop
a squat for us real quick
okay exactly
you ready for the next bit what we gonna
do next is a cozy fit
i'm down so we gonna get you like my
homie
iman you see he's in the crib real cozy
in his gap flex jeans so
i want you to go get your gap flex jeans
about to get this close event popping
help me scoring a bucket
that's why i do like this outfit though
because if i was at the cookout i'll
still give somebody work and you know
what i mean it's still
breathable in my engines
yeah i don't even feel like the sweat
would like run through like
that's for the cozy chill in the house
you're not really going anywhere but
you're still comfortable you got flex
i do wish this shirt was just a size
smaller though
yeah we get you a a smaller shirt just
if you're in the house you want it to
lay on you
you should have like a sage green denim
jacket
you got one oh yes yes my favorite oh
yes
that's your favorite jacket mine too i
like to call it sage
yeah this is a good green sage
so now you got a little bit of color
blocking going on just just just fix the
jacket on you a little bit
like fix the collar fix up okay
okay you know now you got a little bit
of color blocking with the like
different the gray and
like it's kind of like a grayish blue
and you got this sage
green jacket so you could say easy look
up how we feeling about this honeymoon
i love it i actually love
anything simple like that works because
whatever high-top shoe the color
coordination doesn't have to be there
literally your favorite pair of shoes
is always going to go with something
like this you got to fix that collar for
us real quick and then you go you know
what you got to do
we need the the runway walk you got to
give us a walk the twirl
he finna slide in i know it i know he
had a slide
i mean that's what i would do with my
cozy face
all i knew was coming i swear
to dude just like this is called safe
he just
i've never seen sage's color that's why
i was like all right you want to call it
jade
it's jade green it looks like a mute sea
phone
a music man you guessed you yeah
that was a strength all right stand up
one more time let us see that
let's see what's going on with my camera
again
oh man
y'all not gonna have this photo shooting
nah cuz i got the jacket too what are
you saying go put it on
we thought that was a thing i thought oh
yeah mine's
extra large we look good we look like a
group
the way you look at my jacket
i really like this uh what we call it
jade green
no it's muted seafoam yeah
well you need to keep a muted seafoam
jacket with you at all times
seriously like especially with you go to
the ground throwing the brown hair and
stuff like that'll work
muted seafoam wow
all right you ready for the next look
like a date kind of vibe
rock's got another outfit for you just
in case
you know what i'm saying you see
something you might want to go over
there and say something
i'm ready all right i'm ready so i need
to forget i need to go get the blue pair
of gap flex jeans medium wash you see
them the ones i got you need to grab
those you could squish i'm tall in the
middle
see what i'm saying is my stacking
the fit of the jeans are for sure better
because they got like a little more
space in the thigh
like they feel comfortable like you've
been moving them
okay keep your white tea we're gonna
continue with the with the classic white
tea because you can't go wrong
and then you gotta have you're gonna get
the tan
the tan denim jacket
oh okay now button it up we like it
just leave the top one okay that's cool
that's cool just don't go all the way up
okay awesome
awesome how did jesus
honestly like nice
[Music]
like like some someone from france like
a european cut style dude you know what
i'm saying yeah
well i look like a photographer can you
drop down and get your eagle on
in those jeans
you bet not this man
oh drop down and get your eagle on in
your gap flex
jeans go ahead one more time
no okay
to conclude uh i want to say that
my favorite is still the uh
what's up what what give me the give me
the color muted muted
seafoam green muted yeah muted
foam green that muted seafoam green
is still my favorite not to say i don't
like this uh this jacket because
you know what i'm saying this works the
muted seafoam jacket
is my favorite and that look period is
my favorite which you have in the cage
go ahead rox my favorite look is going
to be
the yellow jacket the cargos
and the bucket as far as functionality
and looking good i think that's a
functional fit for what you do for a
living this fit button
up is my favorite with the jeans because
of the whole french moped driver look i
could wear
icon like a moped helmet that would be a
look right there
i wanted to win you're supposed to be on
my side
i'm on my side
i feel you that's the best side to be
honest
i had to take
hey thank you yeah so what we're giving
you is gonna be very complimentary to
either fit
oh hold on wow ready
i'm ready i'm so ready we got here
so we're going to complete your fix
[Music]
these aren't just air max these are
travis scott's these are hard to find
these are cactus jacks
i hope you do like what we put together
thank you so much
yeah man thank you for coming on with us
before we leave can we get one more
picture let's get ready man
hey it was great calling at you dog
of course it was fun it was so fun
getting here
rocks thank you for coming on what thank
you to the gap
your contributions to the drip man
that's the energy exactly the energy
comes with
oh thank you guys